did you take me home to set liam yes
i have to tell uh now go ahead
one little funny story i remember i was
making
star wars the phantom menace and leaves
and lived in studios about 23 years ago
and it was at lunch time and i was
michael was
two so i was carrying him uh
showing him the set at lunchtime and
r2d2 was part
up against forever and uh
i was carrying michael bryan and
pointing things out and he saw r2d2 now
he knew nothing about star wars
so any movies or comics running that
he's two
but he saw this little metallic creature
and he was like this had to get done
from my arms
waddled over to this thing and started
hugging it
which i thought was fascinating
and i remember after lunch i told george
lucas i said george i brought my son to
see
uh you know he he he had to go down and
go over to
to r2d2 and just hugged him
and george wasn't surprised he had a
smile on his face and says yeah he has
that effect
on on children i says but my kid is two
years of age
and uh you know it's a big chunk of
metal
you just he just knew it was cuddly and
comfortable and friendly you know
is this what it's like behold when you
bring dates home
[Laughter]
pretty much he's got the lightsaber out
he's uh yeah
man going hi have you seen taken one two
and three
did you see the phantom menace
[Music]